los huesos proporcionan apoyo para el
cuerpo y ayudan en el movimiento
la ubicación en donde se unen dos o más
huesos se llama articulación las
articulaciones pueden ser inamovibles
ligeramente movibles o totalmente
movibles
una membrana sinovial rodea las
articulaciones móviles en el interior de
la membrana sinovial el líquido sinovial
lubrica y nutre el tejido articular como
el cartílago
el cartílago articular es una dura
cubierta resbaladiza en los extremos de
los huesos que permite un movimiento
articular suave
las articulaciones dan flexibilidad al
cuerpo precisión en los movimientos y
ayudan a sostener el peso del cuerpo
la artritis es cualquier trastorno que
afecte a las articulaciones puede causar
dolor e inflamación
la artritis reumatoide es el segundo
tipo más común de artritis
las articulaciones más comúnmente
afectadas son las muñecas las manos las
rodillas los tobillos y los pies
por lo general se produce en la misma
articulación en ambos lados del cuerpo
también puede afectar a otros órganos en
el cuerpo tales como los ojos
la piel
el corazón
los pulmones
los riñones
el sistema nervioso
y el tracto digestivo
la artritis reumatoide es una enfermedad
autoinmune esto significa que el cuerpo
se ataca a sí mismo por error en la
artritis reumatoide el sistema inmune
ataca a los tejidos de las
articulaciones y los órganos así es como
sucede
los glóbulos blancos del sistema
inmunológico se trasladan a la
articulación
estos liberan sustancias químicas
denominadas citoquinas que atacan a las
células de la membrana sinovial
estos químicos hacen que las células
sinoviales liberen otras sustancias
destructivas
también hacen que la membrana sinovial
desarrolle nuevos vasos sanguíneos y
forme un área engrosada denominada paños
con el tiempo a medida que crece el pan
nos invade y destruye las zonas de
cartílago y hueso en el interior de la
articulación
la inflamación provoca una acumulación
de líquido en la articulación por lo que
se inflama la articulación con el tiempo
el espacio de la articulación se hace
más estrecho y se puede producir
anquilosis
la anquilosis es la fusión el
crecimiento conjunto de huesos en la
articulación
esto resulta en la pérdida de la
capacidad de mover la articulación
no hay cura para la artritis reumatoide
sin embargo los médicos suelen
prescribir diversas combinaciones de los
siguientes medicamentos que tomados en
conjunto pueden reducir la inflamación y
el dolor y retrasar el daño articular
estos incluyen medicamentos
antiinflamatorios no esteroideos aine y
esteroides y fármacos antirreumáticos
modificadores de la enfermedad
estándares o efe rm
si los efe rm convencionales no
funcionan los médicos pueden resultar
medicamentos más nuevos denominados
biológicos también conocidos como efe rm
biológicos la terapia física y
ocupacional junto con el ejercicio de
bajo impacto pueden aumentar la fuerza
muscular y ayudar a mantener las
articulaciones flexibles
para la artritis reumatoide severa en la
que otros medicamentos no han sido de
ayuda el médico puede recomendar un
procedimiento quirúrgico por ejemplo
puede recomendarle un procedimiento de
reemplazo de la articulación también
conocido como una artroplastia para las
articulaciones que son difíciles de
reemplazar le puede recomendar la fusión
de articulaciones también conocida como
artrodesis durante este procedimiento se
retira la articulación y los huesos se
fusionan con un injerto de hueso
otro procedimiento quirúrgico para la
artritis reumatoide severa es una
sinovec tome a durante este
procedimiento se retira la membrana
sinovial que rodea la articulación
en algunos casos quizás sea necesario
reemplazar una articulación artrítica
por una articulación artificial
para obtener más información consulte
con un proveedor de atención médica